I'm wad guruswami I'm a senior scientist
here at the Simons Institute for the
theory of computing and also currently
it's acting interim director with me
today is nikel sasta who has just joined
us this summer as our newest senior
scientist welcome nich oh hi r hi um so
how did you first get interested in
theoretical computer science um well
let's see there were a couple of events
like during undergrad uh I mean I was at
in the beginning I was mainly interested
in in math and also I was doing research
in non theoretical computer science
namely like databases and so in this
database research I somehow um uh I went
with my adviser to vldb one year and and
where was your undergrad it was at Union
College in Upstate New York which is
like a small liberal arts college with
like 2,000 people and
concy and so um so I went to
vldb and I I remember going through all
the talks and one talk really jumped out
at me and it was a talk about using
graph algorithms to optimize queries
like probably something that's being
studied of the type that's being studied
in the program here and I just didn't
know that there was this thing where you
could do you could do math in this
computer science context so that was
one important event and then um I guess
another one was um I mean it was really
influenced by the people who mentored me
like my math adviser
recognized that maybe this is something
I would like and so he he showed me some
problem which which was some some simple
algorithms problem and that was like the
first thing I proved that wasn't known
before and that just felt incredible so
great yeah it was kind of it was really
influenced by these two advisers that I
had I mean and then well finally I mean
okay I I I still had I didn't make up my
mind I applied to half grad schools in
MA in uh theoretical computer science
and half in set theory which was the
other thing I was interested in
and then I actually couldn't make up my
mind even on April 15th or whatever I
just couldn't make up my mind so I asked
for an extension and then some unnamed
faculty member at unnamed University
told me that listen if you do set the
there's no way you're going to get a job
I was like
okay nice path and it's great to have
you among the theorists for um and what
research questions are you interested in
these
days um so uh uh I spent the last couple
of years thinking a lot about um
questions in linear algebra so I mean it
kind of goes back to a conversation I
had in 2018 with Peter Berger who told
me he's like you know listen like
there's this problem like uh you know
given a matrix diagonalize The Matrix
like comput it IG values and igen
vectors and this is something we we all
learn in undergrad and okay for those
who don't know igen values and igen
vectors are a mathematical concept that
corresponds to Computing let's say
resonant frequencies and resonant modes
of physical objects so this is something
that uh felt like this should be just
totally understood like you know to the
level of sorting or something where we
have algorithms we have proofs that they
always work and somehow this should be
something that's very understood but he
was like actually you know the best
known algorithm for this problem is like
n the 10 wow and so this was like really
striking to me and so I was like well
how can that be like how is that
possible so that then I really got into
this area of trying to find provably
fast algorithms for for diagonalizing a
matrix and this worked on this for a few
years and eventually made quite a bit of
progress still not we're still not at
the level where it's as welled as
sorting but it's um you know it's
comparable to the time for multiplying
matrices um so that was what I what I've
been doing in the last couple of years
and that kind of brought in um I mean
the reason it brought in ideas from from
math like random Matrix Theory and that
kind of explains why it probably wasn't
known 50 years ago or
something um but yeah I I'm kind of at
an inflection point right now I'm really
influenced by some things I've seen at
the Simons Institute I found for example
the the quantum program the summer very
exciting and I I've been kind of a
Quantum groupy for many years I've been
kind of just watching and like reading
papers and haven't done anything yet and
Quantum is l on steroids some so I think
it's about time and I think I'm probably
going to start working on Quantum Markov
chain oh excellent mhm and um speaking
of your connections with the Simons
Institute I mean you were a research
fellow in the first semester of
programming at Simon Institute in the
Big Data program if I recall right and I
think you've been a participant in
numerous
programs since you know maybe over 10 in
fact uh yeah that's the official yeah
two varing deg I'm sure but still it's
really impressive number shows your I
guess wide ranging interests and also
you know how Simon Institute connects
with your research so what what makes
the Simon Institute such an important
menu for theory of computing and um how
do you see the Institute has having
evolved during the years you've been
part of it um I mean okay the most
obvious change uh to me is you know in
the beginning uh when it was new uh you
know when visitors came in it would be
their first time and it was uh it was
kind of this new exciting thing that was
happening um and now it just feels like
people are coming home or something like
cuz everybody you know many people
who've come here have been here before
it feels kind of very cozy it feels it's
a lot louder which is really nice like
it it just feels it feels more like like
coming to a coming back home than than
to some new place where you have to be
somewhat for formal I mean that's the
most obvious difference uh to me um in
terms of the programming obviously you
know there's been a shift there's an
increasing emphasis on certain research
areas notably machine learning and and
Quantum um and
um yeah I mean I guess I guess the
community has or or the the the core
topics of theorical computer science
have grown in in in this time period and
that is one of the goals of Simon
Institute which is um
to really engage with adjacent
communities by inviting people from
those communities over and really it
does take a whole semester to create
that kind of Engagement and I can I mean
I can really see that that's actually
happened the community has actually
grown as a result of the programs that
we've had here yeah and certainly a lot
of youngsters routinely come through so
it influences them through their career
too it's not just establish yeah I mean
that's one of the nice things right I
guess I mean I guess there's a big
effort in all of the programs to make
sure that a large fraction of the people
are are post talks CU they're the ones
who are going I mean have you noticed
any um any major changes yeah I guess I
mean some of it is I mean when I came as
a visitor it's I mean one thing I've
noticed it's different being here on a
permanent basis than just coming uh here
for 4 weeks or something but I guess
yeah I've also noticed that there's a
lot of increasing energy you know a lot
of visitings not just post talks but
visiting students and some of them have
explicitly told me that sort of even if
they have a relatively good siiz group
in their home institution being immersed
like this in their area for four months
I mean that is an experience you you
know they're very privileged to have and
they realize that and you know you can't
replicate that anywhere however big a
theory group your institution might have
so I think and then this really informs
them and especially for programs with
stradle theory and practice they kind of
come away from it with with a
perspective which really sort of is far
beyond what you would expect somebody
PhD student to have and that can really
have lots of impact going forward right
because it can really inform their
research and stuff so I'm kind of really
excited to see the Next Generation and
and we have already seen that in our
10th anniversary thing some you know
fellows who came through this sort of uh
really thank the institute for sort of
informing this aspect of their research
I think that's going to continue so it's
great you yeah I mean I think it it
really speeds up the process of entering
a new research area right like no matter
how big your theory group or whatever is
you can't have everybody there and even
if you are working in an area it might
say oh there is this this is why it's
really important oh there are all these
other people also interested in it now
I'm really excited you know there's that
also sometimes you know research
especially in theoretical areas can be a
bit isolating like you you and your
problem and you're like okay but if you
see a greater ecosystem in action every
day that can be really sort of uh
energizing I guess yeah yeah and and
simply the type of information you get
is different right you get to talk to
everybody in the field that's kind of
the only way you can gauge the
difficulty of a problem cuz you can you
can know well what do people not know
what do people what have people tried
Etc you just can't find that written
yeah exactly yeah I think there's a lot
of things which exactly as you say you
can't pick up from just papers and
surveys and it's really sort of I think
being in this atmosphere people gain
that that's great so and um and also
speaking of adjacent areas I mean you
are I guess officially mathematician uh
and uh but your interest clearly fit the
kind of research that happens at the
Institute just judging by the number of
programs you have participated in but uh
for those in our audience who may not be
so familiar with the intersections
between math and TCS can you explain
about that and perhaps do you bring and
and you kind of mentioned this a little
bit in your linear algebra part do you
bring a somewhat or random Matrix part
do you bring a special maty flavor to
your work and how do you see that going
forward so uhhuh yeah yeah so so let's
see
so well yeah okay so I'm I'm the same as
everybody else I'm a theorical computer
scientist but I am in a math department
so I have seen how it works in math and
it is a little different so I mean first
of all math is just huge like it's
really much much much bigger than
theorical computer science and so maybe
the uh and and and the important feature
is that the culture in different
subfields of math is very different also
that like you know how how
uh how are problem like who decides what
are the important problems for example
or you know how fast do do like what is
the typical rate of publication you know
are
people um you know in some areas like
Comin roric it's very common to write
you know lots of small papers on on um
on on problems whereas in other areas
it's more common it's expected that
you'll spend a couple of years and write
a paper that's like a you know some kind
of a large
don't um different fields are also I
mean some fields are really outward
looking and and others are are not
others are basically following the
agenda set by some small group of people
and so um there so I mean that said an
overall difference between theorical
computer science and math is that in
math generally at least in pure math the
the goal is just I think mainly
Aesthetics like it's it's purely
aesthetically driven people want to find
proofs that are kind of beautiful and
deep and uncover some interesting
mathematical structure whereas in
theorical computer science we have these
two we have two goals we have this kind
of mathematical depth goal but we also
are motivated by computer science so we
act we we have this goal of being
practically relevant or you know of of
producing uh algorithms that are
efficient which is actually a different
goal from uh I mean I mean on the face
of it a different goal from from just
the goal of mathematical Deb so
sometimes these things align beautifully
and that's kind of the nice thing about
theal computer science that you you you
when you're looking for for for these
nice algorithms you find some new you
know interesting math um and sometimes
sometimes they don't align and that's um
uh you know that's one of the the
hazards of of working in this
field um but
uh I mean that's I don't know that's
pure math applied math is is much closer
to practice I would say than theorical
computer science and one of the things I
hope
to uh maybe increase during my time here
is interaction with applied math um so
strangely TCS has not had that much
interaction with applied math I don't
know in your field is it is it different
um yeah so applied math I guess if you
take things like commics there's at
least been a lot of back and forth you
know between some areas of TCS like Pudo
Randomness notably and Comics but I
guess yeah if you mean more of the sort
of computational things like fluid
dynamics numerical uh analysis and so on
I I guess there's definitely a lot more
potential for interactions say probably
that's what you're uh yeah I mean I'm
I'm viewing Comon rhetorics as pure
math I mean like people who actually
compute things okay yeah um yeah I think
there's there's some element yeah of
that right and it's also interesting you
mentioned that some parts of Applied
math are actually closer to practice
than theoretical CS tends to be because
yeah we have a bigger Road from ALG
development to deployment whereas they
kind of probably develop things kind of
motivated by a concrete engineering or
or scientific simulation need and and so
they are you know the research is very
more closely informed by that right so
that is my sense and that was one thing
I was surprised to learn uh when I
learned more about applied math that
they I mean they actually don't even
necessarily care as much about proofs as
as we do but they really they really
care about the application and so the
the scientific culture is just is very
different um they're not as like we are
still we still have a very pure math
culture we're driven by like big open
problems basically and so yeah and I see
a little bit of that in in sort of my
research area in error correcting codes
it's done by multiple communities one of
which is electrical engineering
information theorist and also by
computer scientists and there's a little
bit of I think they tend to be sort of
they really care about the solutions
being sort of more importable to
practice than say a computer science
perspective would be where we want that
clean theorem with no bells and whistles
everything proved and stuff right and
whereas if it's 90% proved whatever it
means but if it's going to change uh the
way you store or communicate data I
think that's great because somehow it
has a Little Bit Stronger ties to an
engineering view Viewpoint than computer
science which maybe kind of came a
little bit from Math logic and Science
and so on but I think that the Gap is
bridging and that's one of the exciting
thing and you know people at least
understand each other's language and
sensibilities and so that's already
progress uh yeah and that's one of the
things The Institute has been really
good at doing yeah exactly and in fact
we had a program which brought together
you know both sides of the aisle on
coding theory about you know 8 years ago
we do it again next year so yeah exactly
Institute is good at
that
uhhuh yeah I think um yeah thanks a lot
I think that's that's very informative
I'm glad that ask you some questions too
I mean I mean this is kind of a like a
semi new role for you too like one one
and a half years ago something um um
yeah so I mean I so you're you're taking
shafi's place right now um um as as
director just for the semester just for
the semester yeah I mean how how has
that been do you have any any ideas
about what you're going to you're going
to do this semester is it yeah I mean in
some sense I mean the you know the
Institute is in a great place I mean
shaffi is an incredible director she's I
mean her passion and dedication to The
Institute is amazing she's constantly
creatively thinking about how to make
the Simons Institute fulfill its Mission
even better so that really for the
greater good of theory worldwide right
and theoretician so I think so in some
sense all the higher level pieces are
really in good shape and um in terms of
day-to-day thing the Simon Institute is
in fact a really well-run Place uh right
I mean we have the programming is very
well well oiled mhm and um you know the
staff are amazing everything um the
associate director sandani she's really
on top of like programming planning for
all the programs and the workshops and
the uh Outreach lectures and so on so
everything is going so there's um maybe
one of the things I'm sort of thinking
about um is we've had an extremely busy
past two years some of it is just coming
back from sort of coid and you know
people were raring to go and you know we
had lots of exciting proposals so the
Institute has been been kind of running
nonstop literally for two plus years
yeah after Co there was this like in
tremendous energy so I'm sort of helping
planning the programming for the next um
year or two and you know we might sort
of take a little bit of breather and
sort of see if you know have a maybe
maybe kind of go back to normal older
times when it was not maybe as uh hectic
and some of it is also dictated by
external con considerations of like
fundraising and you know logistical
things of space and staff
availability and and so on so that's
something we're planning and on the
other hand we get great proposals so
somehow trying to understand how to plan
for this is something I'm you know
thinking about and also helping shaffi I
mean Shafi I should also say I mean
she's she's still very much engaged in
the higher level aspects of planning
ahead for the ins like fundraising and
stuff so quite remarkable that on
sabatical yeah exactly so it's not uh so
so I'm trying to assist her in some of
those aspects as well trying to you know
both for because we have a very generous
uh match offer on the table from the
Simons foundation for which we you know
we need to sort of do philanthropic
fundraising so but I'm also interested
in our programs are also on The Cutting
Edge and I feel like any federal agency
should really be supporting many of
these activities so I'm trying to also
find out options to um do some
fundraising in um those aspects as well
and the other thing is that as senior
scientist I was a little bit more
insulated um you know maybe I was
focusing more on the fellows program
some of the scientific aspects but I
know and and and I knew some subset of
the staff very well but maybe not the
the entire cre so I'm also hoping to use
this as an opportunity to get know the
operation staff who day in and day out
keep the place running like clockwork
yeah it's amazing how how well run this
instit so I'm trying to get to know them
better and maybe understand also like
what are some of the pressure points and
how we can you know make EAS things for
them and also and that also will intern
and help The Institute run in the same
uh way for the next decade right so
sounds like a real job it is yeah I mean
I would say so yeah so yeah so yeah but
it's but it's great yeah it's um Shafi
deserves this little breather from the
nuts and bolts and I think it's a good
way for me to learn some aspects of The
Institute which I didn't maybe
appreciate that much before
so and and has has has being here um uh
how has it affected you scientifically
like has it affected your research
agenda or how you choose problems um I
mean yes and no um I guess no in the
sense that I tend to be you know you
know maybe I'm still a bit old school so
I'm sort of still working on some
classic themes of the field maybe trying
to slowly push the frontiers of it or
maybe work on some new themes or maybe
newly hopeful themes because of some
recent developments but still it's sort
of sort of old problems for example one
problem various variants of which which
always continue to excite me is
constraint satisfaction problems which
are of course the bread and butter of
you know TCS they being behind NP
completeness PCP theorem unique games
lot of semi-definite programming
algorithms and so on it's amazing how
much Falls in this abstraction yeah it's
it's sort of this sweet spot between
generality and structure so as a result
it's a really great test bed for like
both algorithmic and complexity
theoretic techniques and here there was
this major development of the dichotomy
theorem which gave a precise link
between which problems are easy and
which are hard and why are they easy and
not just that but also why are they easy
and you know why are they hard so is
there like one sentence explanation of
why so I mean if if I have to say it at
a high level it some sense if your
solution space offers some higher order
symmetries then um you can somehow turn
that into an algorithm you can sort of
think of it as some sort of a discrete
convexity so a lot of problems in
continuous optimization are easy because
of convexity so there is an analogous no
motion you can capture here using
something called polymorphisms
essentially homomorphisms from higher
powers and that somehow seems to hold
the key and it's very precise and that's
amazing you know as as a scientist this
is what you sort of you know you want to
understand nature you want to understand
why something is the way it is and this
explains it for efficient algorithms
which is a very complex phenomena but of
course only for the stylized world of
constraint satisfaction problem so one
of the things which would be great is to
sort of be emboldened by this and push
this further Beyond constraint
satisfaction and I'm working on some
some models and um uh on that one of the
prominent one is something called
Promise constraint satisfaction it's
probably a bit technical to Define in
this scope but I would say a
prototypical problem is like approximate
graph coloring I can give you a graph
tell you it's three colorable but I can
ask you hey can you at least color it
with 10 colors right this is a problem
we currently don't know the complexity
of so that's the promise that you yeah
the promise I give you a stronger
guarantee I hold you to a weaker
requirement so that's something I work
on I've also been um you mentioned
various things about linear algebra so
one of the things I've been uh involved
in recently is algorithms for the semi-
random instances of constraint
satisfaction problem where a lot of
spectral techniques have led to some
nice algorithms and um and this also has
led to some interesting applications in
coding Theory which is the other you
know main hat I wear so where we used
some of these CSP algorithms as a way to
um prove some lower bounds on certain
kinds of eror correcting codes called
locally decodable codes so that was sort
of very nice when these this interplay
between the spectral world and this
discr yeah you can sort of think of a
code as a collection of constraints and
you can then Pro non-existence of a code
by basically saying that that collection
of constraints cannot have a satisfying
assignment and so and you can take that
connection and it actually leads to the
state of the art results in one model
which is nice yeah actually one of my
favorite when I was a grad student one
of the first papers I read was your
paper on uclean sections of L1 okay
which was this incredible kind of blend
of coding Theory and continuous you know
uh High dimensional geometry insights
yeah there are some things related to
that also we recently worked on but
again there are many things we don't
know there for example if you throw
sparity into the mix we don't know what
exactly happens so in coding Theory I'm
also excited by I think as a field it's
very interesting because you get some
very deep mathematical questions but we
somehow naturally arise from some Modern
technological reasons for example
distributed or cloud storage led to a
host of new demands on what the code
should yeah offer and that leads to
often some very deep questions and it's
also very practically relevant you know
saving lots of um you know huge amounts
of money for cloud providers yeah my
understanding it's actually been
implemented yeah you know many of these
things are implemented and the math is
very very nice for example recently we
had some work using uh non-commutative
polinomial which giv some state of the
art codes which probably you know are
Deployable and maybe already deployed I
don't know um so so that aspect uh of
coding um theory is um in fact really
interesting so it's a field that where
you can actually have The Sweet Spot
mathematical depth and I mean I tend to
work on the very the mathematical end of
the spectrum but you know there is a
spectrum and uh sometimes you get really
beautiful math questions which have
impact all the way and polar coding is
another example which you which is in 5G
standards but asked beautiful questions
about marting Gales and protic phenomen
yeah that was really starting and so all
this is continuing on in terms of being
influenced by being here I mean one
thing I'm how to pick problems basically
I try to push on these directions in
reacting to what's happening in the the
community but also revisiting old
questions when I have some inspiration
but some of being here I think um I'm
really sort of excited by Quantum error
correction now you know thanks to all
the activity here and working on it uh
as well and I'm quite excited because
it's it's really a new facet but and
there have been really amazing
breakthroughs in the field so it seems
like a good time to you know at least
one should know about these things and
huge breakthroughs yeah and and there
are some interesting things we're
working on and um and some of it is
really influenced by students I mean I
think I've said this before in other
sort of my Q&A when I started here one
of the points I made is the field is
incredibly lucky for the amazing
talented are tracks right in terms of
the students we get in year after year
so so I'm blessed to work with you know
you know amazing students and some of
the research is directly informed by
what they want to work on so so Quantum
is one example I'm also interested in
parameterized complexity these days
because of collaborations with the
student and also on some questions it's
sort of the intersection of coding meets
communication complex te meet streaming
there are some surprisingly interesting
questions in that Nexus which haven't
been explored and and you know some sort
of thinking about some of these things
and these are really you know things
which um have happened for me because of
being here and at Berkeley not just the
Institute but also the Berkeley the
group so yeah same I mean this interest
in Quantum is somehow largely because I
have like half my students that's what
they want to do right yeah yeah and uh
yeah they have a great opportunity here
to get a wide perspective on Quantum you
know they teach me so yeah so yeah so I
think it's it's exciting yeah of course
busy to juggle all this with other yeah
I don't know how you do it cuz I keep
seeing your name as being you know the
editor of such and such journal and like
moderating the archive like I don't know
how does all this well yeah you know
have good collaborators and good
colleagues and uh I guess that's that
really helps yeah well thanks n and and
this has been a lot of fun and um thanks
to all of you in our audience and uh
please don't forget to like And
subscribe and we hope to see you in
Berkeley and at the Simons Institute
soon thank
you